[Music]
one of the moments that i was star
struck was i was at some event or a
party and i looked over and saw morgan
freeman
and i'm just such a huge fan of his and
i actually
went up to him and said
i please be nice to me i'm such a fan
this really really bummed me out if it
went any other way and he was so kind
i because not everybody's nice i have to
say that he's really nice
a time that i was star struck um
a very funny story
i'm hanging out with will and family and
we are on this little boat we're in
miami and we get to uh you know another
boat and i realized oh we're going to
that boat i turn around
and i'm handing willow
off to someone
right so i'm taking willow off the boat
and i'm giving willow she was young at
the time right and i turn around and
it's tom cruise
and i've got the total dumb look on my
face like oh snap
so it was tom cruise in the middle of
miami harbor
a moment i was star struck was at oh
gosh it was actually uh my first time
meeting whitney houston and i'll never
forget
uh meeting her in the lobby of at the
time it was called a hotel miko
and um we walk over
and
she
is just beaming this beautiful beam of
light
and she says hello
and it's literally like the rest of the
planet just said
this is a test of the emergency
broadcast system and i couldn't hear
anything else i was just
so
i mean she's my hero and she's the woman
that inspired me to sing so i tried to i
remember come back to my body because i
felt like it was an out-of-body
experience out of my experience and um
i sat there and listened to everything
that she said
but i still like in my body was crying
and just freaking out and i will never
forget that moment i will never forget
how kind she was and how she would um
just check on myself and the girls and
i love her god rest her soul i love her
one time i was at the globes and i
remember me and sofia vergara were
hanging out backstage and
we both saw meryl streep just chilling
and it was just three of us backstage in
this changing room and i remember sophia
and i were both like pushing each other
in front of meryl streep and being like
okay who's gonna go speak to her when
finally she did because she's braver
clearly um but yeah i was i was a little
bit starstruck
[Music]
you